so my name is Chris Tankersley hopefully
you remember me from yesterday but today
I'm gonna talk actually about docker and
some things that we can do and think
about as we start to design work
workflows and move it more into the
development stage docker is one of those
things that has really started to pick
up over the last three four years as a
development tool as opposed to just
primarily a deployment system even
though originally that's kind of how it
was designed so I stole this from the
docker website years ago I don't even
know if this page exists anymore
but doctors build as an open platform
for developers and system ends to build
ship and run distributed applications
and that was primarily its core focus it
wasn't necessarily designed as a
development tool but we make it work for
us because realistically we want our
setups to work all the way from
development to production and we want to
get away from that it works on my
machine mentality so depending on how
long you've been doing development we
went through the same kind of
Renaissance seven eight years ago with
tools like vagrant which made
virtualization a much more attractive
option for doing development because it
fixed a lot of problems doing work
directly on your machine causes
inconsistencies that you don't or that
you don't want to have minor PHP version
differences configuration differences
and vagrant promis'd kind of that same
set up to get rid of the it works on my
machine problem but very few places
actually followed through on it as they
generally didn't use the same puppet or
ansible configs and vagrant that they
actually used in production if they used
any at all docker still kind of has that
problem but one of the big advantages is
in you have a same binary base across
the board so it even lessens that more
and more it's kind of at the bottom of
here docker enables apps to be quickly
assembled from components and eliminates
the friction between development QA and
production environments
and that's really the big thing that we
worry about as developers is making sure
that our work flows from dev to
production are as seamless as possible
and we can reuse those environments as
much as possible so I'm gonna spend just
a small portion of time on exactly what
a container is if you are not familiar
with how docker works already I would
suggest maybe going to one of the other
talks I'm not really gonna go over the
basic fundamentals of docker above and
beyond this because how a container
works is a very important topic so if
you're not sure how docker works or
exactly how you want to get like compose
set up this is gonna be a little bit
slightly higher level but I want to make
sure that we're all on the same page on
what a container is because what
containers are kind of influences how we
actually structure our workflows so in
the really old days of my previous job
last year you would deploy code to a
bare metal server and in all honesty 80%
of the projects I work on probably still
get deployed to a bare metal server it's
really easy to setup
it's very non resource intensive but
from like a large enterprise setup or
like you look at someone like
digitalocean or AWS or Rackspace it's
super inefficient so we've got a fake
little computer here with some processes
being used in a normal setup you've got
your processes up there in green they
talk to an operating system and the
operating system talks to the hardware
and this works really well if your PHP
application says I want Ram it asks the
operating system instead of having to
understand how to talk to the actual
physical hardware to get that Ram now
there is a little bit of overhead our
operating system takes up some resources
so that's our graph on the side we're
gonna say our operating system takes up
10% CPU 20% ram and then our application
sits on top of that and gobbles up some
more of that makes total sense we use
resources but if we have a single
application on a single server that's
really inefficient but we really don't
want to overload
servers too much and there are issues
especially security issues with shared
hosts so a lot of place has moved over
to virtual machines and this worked
great this is why vagrant was so
powerful but there's a lot more resource
resources used with all this
so generally with a virtual machine we
still have our base operating system we
have the hardware at the bottom but then
we have this intermediary layer called a
hypervisor sometimes that's built into
the operating system sometimes it's a
completely separate software product
like VirtualBox you have things like
hyper-v and Windows which kind of blur
that line but basically the hypervisor
is an intermediary between the
virtualized operating system and the
real one so whenever you deploy an
application you get a whole new
operating system with all the processes
on top of it so our resource usage goes
up but we get the better separation of
concerns between those individual
machines that's great for big companies
like AWS and Rackspace and stuff because
they can shove more operating systems on
a single machine not worry about them
clobbering each other with different
configuration needs or whatever and you
get some benefits of being able to like
move them around through like some of
the various VMware technologies you can
do cool things like hot-swap VMS with no
downtime but there's a lot of overhead
with that because your PHP application
needs to read a file PHP talks to the
virtualized operating system which then
has to talk to the hypervisor which then
has to talk to the real operating system
which then has to ask the hard drive for
the information and then it has to flow
all backup how many people would here
use OS mac OS would docker that's why
it's so slow because we cheat and I'll
talk a little bit more about that in a
bit so but what containers do is lets
you run everything bare metal but just
separates out the processes themselves
into little walled gardens so here we've
got them walled off in the red with our
VMs comes up kind of brownish on here
but our VMs are separated by the red
boundary here containers we do the same
thing but you'll notice there's no
mediary layer so if PHP asks for a ram
it's going to ask the actual operating
system and the operating system will
give it Ram the separation just becomes
what the processes can actually see
alongside themselves so they're
literally just walled processes so in a
normal setup you have a kernel sitting
at the top 90% of the time it's gonna be
some sort of Linux kernel so we're gonna
fake it and say it see a bunch of kernel
here and that has its own world view so
you know everything that's in the root
directory yet your been your Etsy or var
WW clients whatever and when you run
processes they talk directly to the
kernel and the kernel by default looks
at that view all a container does is
create a new view and point a process to
that new view that new view gives us
some things like not being able to see
other people's processes getting your
own separate network topology all kinds
of nice little things but a high level
all it's doing is just creating another
little world inside your system so
docker itself when you get right down to
it is just vagrant four containers
docker doesn't actually do anything
magical it's using existing technologies
docker nowadays especially is an entire
ecosystem so we get this kind of muddled
terminology with like when we say docker
what exactly are we talking about 9
times out of 10 you're probably talking
about docker engine which is the actual
thing that you know the command line
you're typing into and the API that it's
talking to you have a couple other
things on top of that like machine
compose and swarm though I really should
probably take swarm out at this point
cuz nobody uses it it failed in the
market but you've got docker compose for
your orchestration and docker machine
for building machines that do docker so
where a lot of the pain points come in
especially as you start to talk about
docker with teams is how it actually
works for you individually on your
machines so if you're like me and
despite having a macbook i generally
actually do most of my programming on
Lennox
so it works out of the box using a bunch
of built-in things into the Linux kernel
because Dockers primarily actually a
Linux technology it takes advantage of
things like C groups and the way it
handles processes and visibility
straight out of the box it can use a
variety of different container
technologies under the hood but
primarily it's just talking to a Linux
kernel because it talks to a Linux
kernel the other two options Windows and
Mac OS all actually have a virtual
machine in there which eats up some
resources and causes some additional
pain points because you're probably not
deploying to a docker install on Windows
or a docker install on OS X I'll put a
little asterisk next to that so with OS
X most of your problems you're gonna run
into our because of that virtualization
layer it doesn't quite handle port
binding the way that it does in Linux or
it will in production ignoring that
you're probably running like kubernetes
and stuff in production but just
straight docker it works a little bit
differently because you can do different
port bindings and docker expects ports
to work a specific way and they kind of
fudge a lot of that in OS X because of
the XIV relation layer that layer
actually has a really poor i/o
implementation so if you're using layer
of basically anything had a symphony
base that uses a lot of annotations
reading and a lot of i/o there IO layer
at the operating system level is super
inefficient which is what causes all of
the slowdowns it's not actually a docker
problem but it's also a problem you'll
never have in production it exists
solely because of that virtualization
layer Windows actually has three
different ways to run containers all
fully supported by Microsoft and docker
the bottom two are the most common use
cases for people so you have hyper-v
containers where there is a virtual
there is a virtual machine running like
OS X it sets up a small little Linux
machine actually running a distribution
called movie Linux and runs everything
in there the newer style way which is
still technically in beta preview is the
ws l2
stuff do we have anybody in here who
runs Windows at these some Hampl i WSL
to and everything is wonderful I love it
it works with native containers but
still actually in a virtual machine
because wsl too has moved to a virtual
machine w cell one doesn't use a virtual
machine it actually has this weird
translation translation layer to turn
POSIX stuff into native windows calls
which is why there was no overhead with
WS l1 w SL 2 introduces a tiny amount of
overhead but they've done a ton of work
to get that to work it's not actually a
full-on Linux installation though so if
you need things that use like system D
doesn't work but docker is working with
Microsoft to actually make that all work
itself Windows is in a unique position
as well because they actually have a
native server technology that they kind
of worked with docker to do you can
actually dock rise Windows programs
windows core perhaps so dotnet can
actually be distributed as a Windows
container or what they call a server
container and you can deploy that on
Server 2016 and up and I believe Windows
pro and up through docker docker desktop
so if you're building Windows
applications are not in add applications
you can actually compile them as a
Windows binary and ship them off as a
container
there's no VM and I'm involved because a
windows binary knows how to talk to a
Windows kernel there's no need for an
intermediary layer we have to use
virtual machines because we tend to run
Linux binaries on non Linux systems so
you can't expect a Linux binary to
understand how to talk to a Windows NT
kernel or the the mach kernel inside OS
X that's why we have those
virtualization layers and they will
probably never go away Apple doesn't
seem to be interested in coming up with
their own kernel setup even if they did
you'd have to get Mac OS containers
which would be separate from your Linux
containers which are separate from what
you probably deploy in the production
there is the kind of like Linux e the PI
subset of containers because those are
ARM processors not generally x86
processors you have to get high specific
containers for a lot of those things if
you are on an old version of OS X or Y
or on Windows less than 10 or you're not
on Windows Pro sorry pay the upgrade fee
to Windows Professional there is docker
toolbox I do not suggest using it at all
many of you are laughing but it's using
VirtualBox which is has its own
performance problems especially with the
the file mounting system so if you think
it's bad on OS X natively it gets worse
with docker toolbox so they offer it but
it's it is definitely a best-effort kind
of thing you will have much less
headaches just up upgrading your
operating system level as much as you
can or paying the license fee to go from
home to pro if you are in an environment
where your company says no I don't know
really how to help you install a Linux
virtual machine but I'd really caution
you to not standardize on docker toolbox
I've been giving this talk in various
forms for many many years and we have
finally gotten to the point where I
think it's very comfortable to say we
don't use docker for everything anymore
it really is turning into a development
layer tool containers are not just
docker in fact in production you're
probably not actually running docker I
mean people in here running kubernetes a
good smattering of you it's probably not
using the docker engine under the hood
it actually uses a different container
technology under under there the cool
thing is all of these different tools
are talking to each other so you can use
all of those things back and forth
and you can reduce that friction even if
you're not using the tooling from top to
bottom
red hats been working a lot on their pod
man tool
which is a rootless version of running
containers it can run docker containers
and it has its own it uses the standard
there's a standard for how you should
build images and things like that and
it'll use those as well once they get
all of dock the docker compose
translation stuff handled I'm going to
probably assume that's what a lot of
people are gonna run start running in
production for simpler applications
kubernetes has one the distributed like
multi node system so i'm not gonna get
into like production level stuff here
because that's that's a whole other ball
of wax but just remember that docker is
a single portion of the ecosystem not
the entire ecosystem so probably one of
the best ways to think about the
workflows for what you want to do is
this idea of a 12 factor application
I believe it's 12 factor net has a list
of really good ideas to think about as
you're building distributed applications
and even if ultimately you're not going
to have an application that needs to
scale to hundreds of containers because
docker was designed with distributed in
mind 12 factor applications give us a
lot of things to think about and
implement as we start to add workflows
to our things because there are a lot of
anti patterns and docker that you can
really fall into because they're easy
but that will make production deployment
very hard and if you follow many of
these workflows you're actually going to
get to a point where pushing to
production should be fairly seamlessly
even if currently you're deploying to a
bare-metal server and you're just using
docker for development
so couple these are gonna sound really
really obvious is anybody in here not
using some sort of some sort of version
control even if you're still using CBS
is anybody not using version control
this is the first conference in a while
we're not at least not one person has
risen their hand you want to keep
everything in version control for many
obvious reasons but the big reason for
that is you need to start keeping track
of everything in time you should have a
single repository for every full
application that you're deploying I
don't care if it's a micro service or a
monolith or whatever everything for an
application goes into a singular
repository I've worked on some
consulting contracts where you have your
config stored in a specific directory
your application and another for example
they're building an application
currently in vagrant so that has its own
config repository and the doctor stuffs
in another one and you marry those two
things together when you do a deploy
that stuff gets out of sync anything
that you need for your application
goes into the repository sans like
private configuration thingies if you're
not tagging your releases now begin to
tag them for many of us this is probably
kind of a thing but there's many places
that don't tag any of their releases you
want to start getting in the habit of
being able to say I release this thing
on this day picks ember pick date based
pick incremental I don't care but pick
something consistent that you can point
back to and say that I deployed version
5.3 on this day I can go back to five
point three and look at it as of that
snapshot does anybody ever move to tag
you are better than some fortune 500
companies I've worked with you can move
tags you can delete them and retag
things don't ever do that because then
you lose confidence and what a version
number is one company I consulted for at
one point we had five different versions
of those it was 2.3 of an application
deployed to customers you could not
guarantee 2.3 was the same for us
murder customer doing tech support for
that was a nightmare for that team
because they literally had to figure out
which get commit would that two point
three point it to so don't ever move a
tag if you tagged something and you find
a bug congratulations you have a new tag
you don't move the other one I don't
care if you found it four hours after
you make a new release and run your unit
tests you're not hearing you tests run
unit tests I love this debate model of
sources micro-services is anybody
considering moving the micro-services
ask yourself really heavily why you're
moving to a micro service there is
nothing wrong with a properly
constructed monolith if you cannot
construct a monolith now you cannot
construct a micro service if you're
breaking up a monolith congratulations
your monolith now exists on five
different servers my micro services have
their place but you really need to treat
them as separate applications not as one
big global application each part of your
micro service needs to be treated as
some sort of third party service I have
no control over Twitter so if my
application relies on Twitter I have to
be completely separate from them
Twitter's not going to say oh hey by the
way we're gonna break this in six months
make sure that you're up to date and
that you deploy on March 25th because
we're also going to deploy if you have
to have that level of granularity with
your deploys you just have a monolith
that you've broken up and now just have
to figure out all that coding stuff
micro services are not bad but you have
to treat them as separate applications
if you store all of your micro services
and let's say a gigantic mono repo
congratulations you have a monolith
treat any micro service you have as a
separate project completely they can all
be handled by the same team but they
have to be thought of as complete
concrete separate applications in their
own repository with their own deploy
steps with their own configuration
kind of like with the bare metal stuff I
generally just build monolithic
applications because they work they can
scale just as well so if you're gonna
move to micro-services especially if
you're breaking up a monolith ask
yourself what you're gaining out of it
before you make that step it might look
like it will help you with docker but it
probably won't this is another dull one
for us as PHP developers but you should
declare all of your dependencies don't
do something like commit your vendor
directory to your repository it's bad
and gets you in the habit of editing
those files with no kind of way to
actually audit those if you need to
update but you need to explicitly
declare and isolate those dependencies
regardless if it's a package.json a
composer dot JSON whatever else you're
using for your application hot take of
the day commit composer dot JSON and
your composer lock files both of them
the only time you don't do that is when
you're distributing a library but at
that point you're not building
containers so it doesn't really matter
so like my day job I work on the PHP SDK
at next bow we don't ship a lock file
because that introduces some
compatibility issues with people trying
to build their stuff sometimes guzzle is
a great Collider with our stuff if we
ship it composer talk file so we just
ship it composer dot JSON if you're
shipping an entire application commit
your lock file that way you get the
specific version that you know works
with all of your tests and all of that
it also helps if you need to rebuild an
older version so that you make sure you
get the old version of the libraries
you're using and you can debug those
properly one company I worked with we
didn't commit the lock file so if we had
to go back to an old version for a
customer because I just hadn't upgraded
I got newer versions of libraries which
may introduce slight bugs despite how
well people follow cember sometimes
those things slipped through and maybe
they were being caused by a library bug
that has since been fixed in a patch
update but we would never know because
we didn't keep a lock file and kind of
along that when you're talking with
docker also commit all your
docker files to that same repository
that you keep everything else in your
docker file is a dependency it tells you
what image you're going to be building
from and the steps you need to build it
so that needs to live alongside the rest
of your codebase for configuration
you're going to have to look at how
you're gonna split that up but
ultimately you want to start storing
your configuration files in the
environment itself not as files or dot M
files or whatever you want to make sure
that your application can just request
whatever it needs from the system and it
will make life much easier to deploy
anything that's environments this
specific should move to these
configuration variables if you want to
ship like a default like set pagination
automatically to 25 or you know a
default timezone for you know a new
customer to deploy or whatever that's
not quite so bad but things like where's
my database located where's my caching
located where are my PHP servers at
those things should start to move to
environment variables we sometimes get
in the habit of being stuck on like oh I
shipped a dot M file so we're kind of
doing it but if you're shipping a file
you're still kind of doing it wrong dot
M exists so that we can replicate
environment variables in development not
as a way to actually deploy them this
makes it a lot easier to deploy your
code because you can pull an image down
give it some config variable config
environment variables and start it up
you don't have to edit any files you
could just point it to your dev database
or whatever and move those things around
it's a lot less you have to maintain in
the containers themselves as you go
through and you think about okay when do
I need this configuration how do I pull
it out and you just start to say well I
need configuration just start using get
M your code cares less about what
external services it's talking to and it
makes you think about where you're
actually hard coding things end for
docker itself depending on how you're
actually in
your application if you're just doing
like a real basic apps you know
prototyping something you can use the -
II command or the - II parameter and do
multiples of them to do var name equals
value and that will pass them in as a
normal environment variable if you have
a lot of them that you use commonly you
can use - - EMV - file and pass it in
any file that has all of these things
skeleton out as well and you can use
them in parallel so if you want to
change something real quick you can
throw a dashi in there and and kind of
override stuff if you're using docker
compose you can also specify this so
there is an environment file and an EMV
section in docker compose if you want a
hard code that kind of stuff but get in
the habit of pulling those things out
and tracking them that way instead of
worrying about what goes into a
configuration file in speaking of that
anything that is not your application
treat as a third party treat is
something that you don't actually have
any control over so one big thing we do
like when we talk to database server
usually like MySQL we just say connect -
go on localhost well with docker you
don't have a concept of a local socket
you technically they're there but you
can't talk to my SQL because MySQL is
not running in your container you need
to get in the habit of talking to
everything over a network but then also
thinking about well if it's over a
network it's technically external how do
I handle failures how do I handle the
network latency I know most the projects
I work on we will probably use RDS in
production but not development so being
able to separate those things out
through things like the configuration
files but that's still treating it as a
network resource really come in handy
there's less I have to do in my
application code if I just assume it's a
network request across the board you
don't really have to start thinking
about anything that's running locally on
the box like what do I need to have on
the machine for my application to run
your application just needs whatever it
has
everything else is external you can do
things like scale up your my your
database server through proper database
scaling techniques cuz don't run your
database and docker that's not what it
that's not how they scale but you can do
take care of things specifically and
then if you need to swap out to a third
party service like a SAS or whatever you
can run fake versions of them locally
and then point the the real ones in in a
real-world environment if you're using
environment variables it should just be
an environment variable config change no
code changes and it makes it a lot
easier to scale up especially as you
start to scale up individual containers
in the backend which is another thing
we'll consider but you can if you start
to treat everything as external you can
scale your individual pieces of your
application what's easier
there's nothing specifically inherent in
docker to do this this is something
that's probably gonna be a code change
for you but it is something to consider
as you're starting to architect your
application and and build the workflow
for yourself your build release and run
steps should be separate concrete stages
that individually can be run by
themselves and re run by themselves with
the same output so you should end up
with actually three steps every time you
do a deploy the first one is your build
step that's gonna take all of your
dependencies compiles any files you have
like if you're for the most part for us
it's gonna be pulling down composer and
probably running npm install but if
you're using like python if it's got to
compile any files in the backend to do
that and you'll get some sort of
artifact out of that depending on what
you're using that might be a tar file
for docker it's probably gonna be an
image file but this will be a thing that
has no configuration or deployment
information in it whatsoever this is
just a thing that I can put on another
machine with some configuration and have
it work your release step will pull a
build artifact off the shelf and then
start to prep that and put that into
production and then your run step will
actually do the flipping from one
version to the next
so for docker itself you want to start
thinking about this build step
being an image that comes with
everything you need to run so with a
standard standard PHP app if we go
really super simple and we're just using
Apache and mod PHP this will be a single
image with all of our dependencies and
all of our code inside of an image that
we store somewhere you can put it on
docker hub you can put it on Amazon
don't care where but we'll have a pretty
phat image with all of the data inside
of it that we need to run our
application we can then pull that off
the shelf and shove it wherever we
ultimately need to deploy it you should
be able to run that build step multiple
times and get the same output you're
using your composer not lock file you'll
always get the same dependencies pulled
down if you're using the same image
versions they should all be pulled down
the same every single way when you're
ready to deploy you'll grab an image
from the repository and shove it
wherever it needs to go be it my local
machine be it a QA server like a QA
cluster you've got setup or an actual
like kubernetes production but it's
never gonna actually build directly from
the repository you want to get in the
habit of pulling those images from a
registry not building it and then
deploying immediately tag all your
builds and by that I mean come up with a
nice naming convention I usually do it
by date underscore version because I
might deploy like dev versions or QA
versions multiple times throughout the
day as we tweak little different things
but you want to be able to say like
which version am I actually running in
QA in production you know query
kubernetes real quick and be like okay I
know exactly what that is and track all
of your releases somehow this is a
little bit more important if you're
doing like client or consultant where
type of stuff but if you have like a
white box app product that you're
selling off to people tag who and what
goes out to where different customers
probably have different release
schedules and are comfortable with
different layers of work but you want to
know what actually goes out and you want
to know what version you're pulling down
when you start to do development if you
are not building now start small your
build application can be run composer
run npm do whatever npm build stuff you
need to do and then use docker build to
just make an image that can be your
entire build step and then shove it to a
private registry if you don't want to
really worry about it docker hub is
super cheap I'm not gonna tell you how
but there are ways to get around some of
their limits but it's really super cheap
and really easy to get into I like
pushing people that way because AWS can
be very intimidating especially if
you're not deploying to AWS if you're
deploying to AWS use AWS as registry
you're probably already fully invested
in that stack just tack that on for your
build step there's a couple of things
you can look at generally depending on
what how your application is structured
you might be using individual docker
files or you might be using a
multi-stage file but I never keep my
docker file like in the root of my
directory I actually keep it in a
separate docker folder so you can use -
- file to actually point to a specific
file separate from where the the where
you're running the command I always
recommend using - - no - cache docker
tries to be really super helpful in that
if it doesn't need to rebuild an
individual build step it won't but you
really run the risk of getting outdated
layers there out there if you've got
something where you're pulling down a
couple libraries for dependencies for
different things those can get out of
date and if those get out of date you're
not pulling in security fixes that can
be really bad from a lot of stand points
so always get in the habit of not using
a build cache for that
it'll take 40 seconds longer but then
you can fight on the chairs as you
compile all your code ah good a couple
people laughs a couple people remember
that that comic but mostly it's a
security issue like always make sure
you're pulling down the latest
dependencies that you have and then do a
- - pull that make sure you're pulling
the latest version of whatever your base
images again to make sure that you're
getting all of the security updates and
things like that three or four years ago
there was a really bad outbreak where
various versions of Bosch had a lot of
security flaws
turns out atonic containers should have
updated but they never did so a ton of
containers went out with a bunch of
Bosch flaws you don't want to have that
happen to you so always do a pull to
grab the latest version and always use
no cash to make sure you're getting the
latest dependencies so you could do
docker build - - no cache in this case
we've got docker in a my docker file is
in a docker PHP folder because of this
example nginx was in its own separate
folder just makes keeping configuration
files separate cleaner so you'd use - F
to pass that in - and then - T will give
you giving your tag name you really
should be using like vendor slash
whatever but I've only got so much
screen space and there's an option that
most people don't really notice with
docker build and that's that the last
parameter for it last argument is
actually where the root of your project
exists you don't have to run docker
build next to your docker file you don't
have to run it anywhere near your code
you can point it to a file and then
wherever your build output is and change
the context where docker the docker file
runs the docker file will run in the
context of whatever that last argument
is so you can have docker build run from
wherever and just point to wherever your
build directory is so a lot of times
I'll actually have that build directory
as like a variable and a shell script
with whatever the last build folder is
because I'll randomize filenames and
then the last thing you can do or one of
the steps in your doctor file you'll do
is you'll just do a copy this is what
trips a lot of people up trying to build
these copy and add if you want to use
add runs in the context of your build
directory not in the context of where
your docker file exists so if I tell it
to look in opt builds 2016 10 10 copy
will actually copy from that folder into
my container from bar WW if I run this
command in the root of my directory but
I supply something it's not going to run
in the root of mine direct
so that's where you can start to split
things up but you have to be really
careful about the context this runs in
because if you're docker files in a
subfolder and you don't change that that
target it'll try to run in the context
of that subfolder not the root of your
project that's something that can't keep
in mind another hot take of the day
executes apps is one or more stateless
processes if you have more than one
process in your container you're doing
it wrong don't at me you're doing it
wrong
docker is not designed to run multiple
processes in a single container it can
but just because you can doesn't mean
you should if your container contains a
supervisor process like supervisor D
you're doing it wrong sorry you're doing
it wrong if supervisor crashes it takes
everything else down with it because
docker will only ever watch one process
at a time it is not designed to run
multiple processes inside of a single
container if you need that functionality
don't use docker use something like lxc
or lxd from canonical those are designed
to replicate an entire machine with a
full init process and run multiple
things at once docker only wants one
process at a time the reason for this
goes back to my very first slide if
you're distributing your application
across multiple servers you don't need
to scale everything all at once so
traditional PHP app you probably have
nginx
and PHP fpm at the at a bare minimum for
your application those are two separate
processes those are two separate
containers don't use supervisor D to
startup both of them because generally
your bottleneck will not be both of them
if you're having slowness serving static
files then you will need to scale up
your nginx end not your PHP end if you
need more raw processing power scale up
your PHP processes this also allows you
to swap out images as you need so let's
say you want to upgrade from five seven
four to eight I don't think we're
building a key
haters yet but let's say when that day
comes you could just swap out that one
image not touch your web server image
and have a lot more fun with that but
make sure that you're not getting in
that anti pattern of running multiple
processes in a single container you want
to get in the habit of like I said
treating everything is an external
resource and if it has a network port
export that you want your services to
live on ports not as sockets this is
built in automatically every container
gets an IP address in docker so you can
reference a mache container by its IP
address and the port on it
this gets people a little bit confused
because if they're running multiple
nginx or let's say multiple PHP fpm
those all are listening on port 9000 I
now have a bunch of things listening on
port 9000 that's awesome but they're all
probably running in their own IP space
and they're all they all have their own
individual IPS so we can get away with
that because we properly separated
everything out as external things you're
already talking over a network shouldn't
be a ton of extra configuration from
that end this will also let you work
with service locators that are port
based there are some that will say oh
this is port 80 we're going to assume
that it's a webserver you will
automatically dump this into a webserver
group I don't personally like those but
there are some that make it makes life
easier for people because we adhere to
the one process for container rule we
can easily adhere to the concurrency
rule which is scale-out via the process
model scale out the things that need to
scale don't scale everything 100% you're
just gonna waste resources you really
have to think about what happens when
your application scales though docker
will not make your application scalable
it will help you deploy multiple copies
but that doesn't mean your codes gonna
automatically know what to do so your
code probably runs perfectly fine right
now with one single application what
happens when you have two of them
running what happens when you have three
of them running if a user uploads a file
how do you know their two processes get
it where are those things being stored
how are you handling that in your
application
Dockers not going to fix that for you
but it allows you to scale out a little
bit nicer in the case of like uploading
a file you might want to consider doing
something like fly system as an
abstraction layer then saying well in
development we're gonna do fly system to
a local folder but in production it's
gonna be an s3 bucket because you're
you're taking advantage of just changing
that configuration at that specific
deployment time but again we're doing
one process per container so we can
scale those things just up and you can
scale up just a container that's needed
docker compose has ways to automatically
scale your containers up and down in
development so if you want to test how
your application scales especially under
load you can say give me ten instances
of HP fbm but two of nginx does anything
fall over as you start to run your tests
ultimately your apps should not care how
many instances of itself are running
just the fact that it is running it
should never know how many copies of PHP
fpm are actually running how many
webserver heads are in front of it it
just needs to know if I get a request in
how do I handle it
docker won't tell your application how
to do that
but it makes it much easier to test when
you add that distribution in I still
haven't come up with a good phrase to
replace the normal one but your
containers are cattle not pets you
should be able to get them quickly and
call them quickly and that's not the
most vegetarian way of doing it if
someone else has a much better way of
phrasing that let me know but generally
like if you're gonna Google stuff treat
him as cattle not as pets they should
start very quick and they should
gracefully shut down I didn't say they
should quickly shut down they should
gracefully shut down docker because it
starts a single instance most of our
applications start pretty instantly
nginx and Apache have almost no boot
time like we don't do a lot of logic to
get set up PHP just kind of starts and
waits for a request they
basis.sometimes take a little bit longer
but docker will start a container pretty
quickly there's almost no difference
between running a native native process
and running a container process what you
really want to start getting in the
habit of handling and this is more of a
coding issue than a workflow issue is
how do you things happen when they shut
down
so what docker will actually do is it
will send a signal turbine signal so
that your application can handle that so
you need it if you have like worker
processes think about how do they
actually shut down you might want to do
something graceful like a stop the
current like finish the current work
unit and don't accept any more caliban's
has a really good book called signaling
PHP if you've never worked with POSIX
signals before it's a it's like a five
dollar eBook I would recommend picking
that up just so you can get in the habit
of working with those things because
what will happen is docker will send a
cig and if it doesn't get a proper
response or it's not timed properly like
you don't you don't tell docker to like
wait longer it will just send this thing
kill and just kill your application
right there for most PHP applications
it's probably not a big deal it really
gets to when you're thinking about
long-running processes and Damons like
if you're running react or workers or
things like that we kind of get this out
of the box Devon production parity use
the same image from top to bottom
and that's kind of the whole point of
docker is being able to use that same
image but in your development process
use the exact same image that you build
in production when you pull it down to
your machine you can do things like host
mount your volumes so that way your code
that your live editing on your your
computer it's injected in but you're
still pulling down that same image
you're using in production work with
your team to make sure that your docker
compose files which should be in your
repository and should be being version
controlled are being properly pulled
down and you're all using that same kind
of static build yes the production image
is probably fairly large but you're
probably not you should really probably
be changing that terribly often
so we want to keep that as similar as
possible that cuts down on a lot of
those those problems and then you're
kind of left with just development
issues where like I ran a composer
update by example for example and that a
new library has broken something or like
weird little machine specific problems
anything that you log treat is an event
stream you never want to get in the
habit of relying on local logs because
they will not exist in production as
soon as you remove a container it gets
pulled out a rotation by default the
logs disappear so on my machine if I do
a docker RM all those logs disappear I
have no way of getting any of those back
the nice thing is docker has various
logging methodologies built into it the
default is JSON so if you do docker logs
it's actually just reading a JSON file
and spitting it out depending on what
you're doing that may work you can tail
it you can you know just just like
running the tail command to not see
everything or to see it live updates but
it's not really sustainable especially
if you've got multiple containers that
you need to watch and you need to
correlate events so these should be all
the main options that you can do out of
the box with no special like additional
plugins what I would probably suggest
especially starting out is using the
fluent D unfortunately there's no log
stash one too fluent D is log stash
compliant because then you can give the
habit of throwing those logs out to a
third party service or at least another
container to log those and get in the
habit of it journal D and syslog are
really good because if you have an ops
team they're probably already remotely
shoving those logs away anyway and they
probably have a system for handling that
so don't go to fluent D if productions
already using something else like work
within whatever your constraints are one
you'll get the added benefit of
everything is logged but - they're much
more searchable because like I said if a
container dies and the system calls it
they're gone you don't get those logs
back you also don't want to get in the
habit of like what we used to do 20-30
years ago or last year like for the most
part for me going onto a server a server
and looking at the Apache logs it's not
sustainable you won't have access to
those clusters now you can host this
yourself or you can pay for a sass if
you're gonna go and do this to push your
logs the elk stack is one that many
people are familiar with you just can't
use logs - you can replace it with
fluent D I'm going to assume most of you
cannot read these examples I'm going to
read through them I'll post these slides
so you can get them later but suffice to
say you're gonna have a new section
called logging in your compose file you
can tell it use fluent D and then
basically point to whatever the
localhost address that you're gonna have
so in this case I'm gonna point it to
localhost and I'm gonna give it a tag
called Apache access and then you can
add a fluent d service to your docker
compose file so you can put this in like
your your dev config but you can run
fluent D inside docker there's no reason
you can't do that
so you'll push your logs from one docker
container to another and you really only
have to pass in a config file and open
up the ports there is one thing you have
to do fluent D does not have an
elasticsearch plugin by default you have
to install it so you'll probably have a
docker file for that just to get that
additional dependency and we'll see
horse-like was that window I'll change
this so that actually links to it I
didn't mean to close my chrome window
but there's some kid fig files you get
set up in fluent D to push it off to
elasticsearch and then you can run
elasticsearch in a container so you can
keep all of your elasticsearch and
Cabana which is the visualization part
you can keep all the stuff in your
doctor compose file scale them up when
you need them shut them down when you
don't and then this can be part of a dev
docker compose file and you never have
to have it push to production production
can push to a fully backed up compliance
SAS setup you've never loo used Kabana
before has a nice web interface horrible
query structure but so down here below
that little graph you can see actually
the actual log file that was dumped out
and you can search through this Jen a
lot nicer and correlate logs from
multiple containers that especially if
you've got five or six fpm containers
running you don't know which container
was actually talked to so you can deal
with that docker logs command though
will stop working if you move it off the
default JSON driver so if you switch to
using fluent D and you run docker logs
you'll get no logs I think unless you're
paying for docker enterprise but I
honestly don't know anybody who pays for
that the example can be cleaned up a bit
there's some port things with that so
when you grab the the slides just keep
note it's very much tailored for a a
slide format then like a true production
format and you want to get the habit of
container izing all of the scripts that
you need to run as commands docker will
actually allow you to containerize your
entire tooling structure as well as the
actual applications that you're running
so in this case we can have a test
runner service and if you specify a
command you could actually tell it to by
default run a command so I can do docker
compose run test Runner and it will run
my PHP unit tests for me if I have
database migrations that I need to run
especially in a production environment
you might containerize that I hate
having stuff installed on my laptop
especially multiple versions primary I'm
a Linux developer I do not understand
how homebrew works with multiple
versions of PHP so I will use docker to
have multiple versions of PHP installed
and I can swap those out based on the
build parameter to different docker
files and then run PHP hundred different
versions of PHP I can run all my NPM
stuff under the various versions because
sometimes you get version locked but you
can start to take all of your commands
throw them in as services and then you
can dock or compose run them just like a
regular command now your tooling
actually moves from machine to machine
and developer to developer further
reducing how much further reducing the
differences between each person's
machine a couple other tidbits well we
got a couple couple minutes left you can
stack compose files to build up to a
specific configuration so docker compose
allows you to specify multiple files
with the dash F flag so you can have a
base docker compose dot llamo file which
just kind of skeletons out your services
and then you can have a production
compose which adds what your external
ports are what extra configuration
variables you need and then even add
about a dev one which might have
different port bindings and does all
your hosts mounting and things like that
so that way it makes it easier to deploy
and you can just stack those compose
files on top of each other so in this
case we might have a docker compose file
which by default says hey use the nginx
docker file open port 80 and 443 here's
our PHP stuff and then MySQL really
you'll notice we're not pushing any code
into here if you were to live edit
through phpstorm
or Visual Studio code the stuff you edit
on your desktop is not going to be
pushed into these containers we're not
doing any hosts mounting or anything
like that we can push that off to a dev
file which does add our volumes which
allow us to do our hosts mounting and
stuff like that so we can start to
actually get that ability to say the
configuration I'm using in production I
can also replicate down to my
development in a true way but also have
an easy way to override for my
development stack one thing I'll do a
lot is I will override the build to a
debug build which has X debug and stuff
like that so I won't ship X debug to
production I'll switch my docker file to
point to one that has X debug installed
and I'll do that through my dev docker
compose and set up all my X debug stuff
as separate environment variables then
to use it you just stack the dash F it
does go left to right and override so
first it'll take docker compose and then
it will layer dev on
that one other kind of little gotcha
is that it for anything that's an array
like ports or volumes it does not
replace it appends so technically in
this example if I'm opening port 80 and
443 from my production one those will
also be open and I don't open like port
8080 on here if I had another ports in
here we would actually have all three of
them open not it won't replace that's
one kind of weird thing to keep in mind
and then when you're doing a deployment
you just do like a doctor compose up or
whatever you're doing use the the
production one and it won't pull in all
the debug stuff another cool thing you
can do with docker compose is it will
actually do variable substitution so if
you put any of your values in dollar
sign curly bracket it will replace that
from a local environment configuration
so you might do something like image is
deployed version underscore PHP it's
whatever I last built so then doing
deployment you can say deploy version
equals 28 T no 525 docker compose up
dash D and then it will actually inject
that into that in variable this allows
you to especially during a build process
use a very generic compose file